you really are not easing me into this
whole Gary what do you want to play with
me do you want to play with me why
aren't you looking at me
where's your looking Abay he's stuck in
the doors spinning around get in there
Oh doing everyone's going in the party
wall everyone's going in timeout
yes that's timeout for all the bad
behaving monsters being a bad tripod
yeah think about why you're there
hello everybody my name is markiplier
I'm here joined by jacksepticeye we're
gonna place hello I'm trying to mess
with this guy he's not moving well he's
dead did you kill him says a lot about
how did you walk off this man I would
love my blood right now yep
oh you dodged oh guy dad hit me trying
to hit me and hit me this is not how
this was supposed to go no howls is
what's worth together no that's not the
point of gmod okay all right fine you
want to work together let's build
something oh sweet Jesus hey you wanna
play with a stop it you wanna play very
lady yes red ant lion over here okay
it's time for like you walking some
robots yo kill him yeah yeah again oh
sweet lord my fort is fort blam ass
you're not allowed okay
no one's allowed in no one named J is
allowed any boxes nothing spawning for
me I don't like it you got one box
that's your fort what a piddly little
fort Oh filling our ammo crates
oh how pathetic your fort is compared to
my glorious four blue house the Irish
build Oh wonder what is some famous
Irish buildings I'm stuck I'm America
we've milk America you built America
with your bare hands well we British
wait what the what are you doing over
there did you do that no I didn't do
anything I'm still building for blam ass
I am
that sounds like gaben - shut up it's
not a gay bar but even if it was they
would be okay so shut up blam ass I
think I started lagging the server so uh
I think my forty's done broke it's no I
didn't
yeah my Forte's done try and hit me okay
okay
I'll shoot one at you or I only got a
grenade so I'll shoot that at y ou ou ou
ou your box is burning oh your fort is
so piddly better I have made this out of
wood
come on bring it on wait that's a bad
idea this uh no yeah my flash boards
what are you doing are you trying to
kill me what happened didn't work then
thrusters at what oh okay I thought you
flew in the air hang on I actually
buried in the ground hang on just okay
yeah finish my countdown get out of here
well that was a good first effort yeah
but we can do better because this is
Irish art no I always end anew this is
Irish and inaudi ah yeah that's not even
close while I was doing Scottish I was
doing Irish for shame oh yeah I never
heard the Scottish accent like this
before I get a rebate of a Scotsman oh
okay so you can actually do it because
you're nearby again so how about yeah
there's just over there I can wave at
them hi can you really know so I'm gonna
go with my same design and you're gonna
get back in there okay okay you ready
cuz it's gonna be fun alright
ten nine go oh I can't swim which oh my
god are you still in what are you okay
Oh
now we use okay ah okay okay I want it
what about I just kept hitting walls in
the ground you went off like a rocket
just sit tight
you're gonna be fine Anna I think you
know what a Rockets I think anymore I
know what I'm doing I'm a whale
biologist more thrusting look like
lampshade no there's thrusters not right
have you played Kerbal space program
yeah and this is how I built them my
ship was called the crashing exploding
so I don't think you want Maya did I go
all right I mean I'm in it I don't know
how I got to third person but I am in
here oh I think you missed oh where are
we going up I hit um you did this again
so I bought you again no no you're doing
doughnuts thank you I know beautiful
sitting there it's as beautiful as the
person who built it and you are
beautiful you don't know me okay okay
this is how Jack built
all right here get in my rocket this is
a much better model than the previous
one so you're missing a wheel ah that
wheel wasn't structurally necessary
anyway so just get in there okay
Lonnie to potato
oh god you can look behind you you stay
up there just leave me up here yeah good
you should angel' me hang on a minute
hang on hang on hang on ma'am you can do
this yeah
no hang on yeah oh there you go oh god
oh god I'm getting dizzy
dude okay that'll be good enough yeah oh
my god what is happening Lee okay you
guys hands are in the air
thank you really enjoy cuz I'm gonna be
I'm gonna be here staring longingly into
your eyes I go on oh god what happened
right anything that we're doing right
now
hey why wouldn't you trust me look at
your face I'm in the chair let's go
oh oh god I'm on this with you oh okay
think your chairs in my gang no I'm
still here that's why no no no hang up
your crappy design doesn't go anywhere
don't make fun of my design it's very
sensitive about itself you're not going
anywhere
exactly yeah there you go yo here we go
get out of here wait oh you're like a
beautiful rocket where'd you go oh Jesus
and then you go in the water that's real
good over whoa your eyes are so
beautiful in London with a bar over
pretty stupid rocket design I got an
even better design like your yellow
really I got an even better design like
classic said that it went so well done
look at this look at this buddy where
Lucas I built it underwater I need to
get out of the water to go all this by
myself is oh oh oh yeah oh I built that
that's so good you you such genius
really good at gmod if you have a ball
stop it
nope why weren't they activating here
goes one hey hey oh no they're not
working just an ethical as far you're on
fire now you just sank of all God whoa
hey buddy look watermelons Marc dinner's
ready really watermelon really
watermelon all the stuff he could have
made you made watermelons babies - cuca
bleep no babies water you're gonna boil
baby boy babies oil baby oil baby oil
I'm looking around laughs right now all
I see are watermelons babies a
hovercraft and blood yeah I would sound
like a fun party huh that's a good time
melon I've lost all respect for you
after your billing about put thrusters
on the baby
Justin's everyone should ask ELISA
something I never thought annual but
everything on a baby how do I launch
this baby into space like it's like some
whole soy dream it's like oh my god what
the hell are you for baby since you seen
this put ago unfortunately I am
you would have thrust her on a baby and
I don't know where it went where'd a
maybe maybe her name is gone yeah there
we go No
bye baby bye baby oh there's a baby whoa
Oh God can't follow it's your fax ticket
okay okay yeah yeah Sammy by me I I say
it like a normal person
how's that room that's stupid you're
communist or something I don't care
you're the only one who says ruin on old
friends make fun of no no no no no I
talked to my brother he says it the same
way it's just the way we were living
family how could I forget
oh that's but that's weird not at all
what I was acting expecting guy to me
and we go unreal
I leave you for five I just know when I
think of Scottish I think of a big burly
man with a big red beard and fire in his
eyes and a kilt that goes up to his
thighs and just like leaves nothing to
the imagination you know you know I'm
talking about you know pardon me
sexy burly sexy brilliant no I think
you're on your own with that one
thinking on your own without boss in
there lumber around tossing their cables
and then go ahead there's a family for
that what what what happened what
happened you just blacked out and
fantasize about big burly Scottish men
what no why would I do that that doesn't
seem right